pour éviter le gaspillage alimentaire la
monotonie dans l'assiette ou de trop
dépensé on doit tout et tous redoubler
des phares mais la charge mentale
incombe encore plus aux personnes seules
défis et joie parce qu'il y en a de
manger en solo
derrière ces fenêtres des gens habitent
seuls et mangent seuls une réalité qui
n'est pas seulement urbaine
au Québec le 30% des ménages qui
habitent seuls sont constitués d'une
personne qui vit seule donc on a une
évolution de la démographie
[Musique]
une statistique en constante progression
qui frôle jusqu'à 50% dans certains
quartiers et pourtant le format des
aliments qui est pas fait pour les
personnes généralement je pense que
c'est un des gros défis c'est comme
ça Bernard Lavallée s'intéresse à
l'aspect sociologique de la nutrition sa
pratique la même de plus en plus à
rencontrer des solos du frigo
le système alimentaire donc ça veut dire
de la ferme jusqu'à l'assiette doit
s'adapter à cette réalité là il y a une
autre alimentaire pour les gens qui vit
seul mais ça va venir avec parfois un
peu plus élevé
[Musique]
si manger seul peut avoir un impact sur
notre sentiment de socialisation ça en a
assurément un sur l'aspect financier si
au moins on savait qu'on ne gaspille pas
il y a beaucoup de formats qui sont
beaucoup trop gros j'ai mieux payé un
petit peu plus cher à l'unité
était 2022 j'ai vu cette publication sur
facebook curieuse j'ai contacté Nathalie
Ferron qui cherchait à bien manger et à
partager les frais en bonne compagnie il
y a des choses que tu ne te fais pas
jambon avec un os une lasagne embarquée
dans une lasagne tu fais pas ça pour
trois portions donc j'ai décidé de
lancer cet appel là et miraculeusement
en 48 heures j'avais une vingtaine de
Oui-Oui oui oui oui c'est trop
intéressant
[Musique]
certaines personnes vivant en solo
s'organisant très pour répondre à leurs
besoins mais les grandes chaînes sont
plutôt frileuses à les accommoder
[Musique]
le prix final qui se retrouve sur la
tablette et déterminer toujours par le
détaillant le coût d'un emballage est
très fortement influencé par la quantité
compte que le fabricant se trouve à
commande alors au final c'est c'est
toujours moins cher en grande production
de produire et d'emballer des plus
grands volumes que des petits le format
de l'emballage aussi un pot de plastique
ou de verre qui est deux fois plus grand
mais pas deux fois plus cher
[Musique]
les chaînes d'alimentation cherchent à
réduire les frais de transport de
manutention de main d'oeuvre ainsi que
les pertes dans ce contexte pas facile
d'exercer un changement les épiciers de
quartier ont quant à eux une marge de
manœuvre plus grande
on a peut-être moins d'intermédiaires
donc ça nous permet puis on a quand même
un bon volume d'achat donc ça nous
permet d'acheter en gros c'est certain
que nos paquets nos emballages je parle
de la viande ou que ce soit les fruits
et légumes on fait des plus petits
emballages parce que on a une clientèle
qui vit peut-être plus seule les enjeux
de prix sont toujours une question
notamment de l'espace de gestion du
stock et de volume de vente lui c'est
populaire plus sa réponse un besoin du
plus grand nombre et plus c'est un
format qui va se trouver à être offert
son niveau de faire bouger le système je
pense que c'est vraiment plus gros que
nous mais en tant que nous on est une
champ épicerie indépendante je pense que
notre volume d'achat nous permet de
pouvoir faire des petits changements que
ce soit dans notre stratégie d'affaires
pour pouvoir contrer ça
et le plaisir de manger dans tout ça les
gens qui vit seul vont peut-être plus
manger rapidement manger sur le pouce
manger des aliments beaucoup plus simple
ou déjà prêts parce qu'il y a cette
motivation là qui est pas là quand on
est seul le principal point positif je
pense de manger ça c'est qu'on a pas à
faire de compromis on peut toujours
manger ce dont on a envie et si on peut
peut-être Lorraine la fortune habite
aussi seule elle est une de celle qui
ont répondu oui à l'annonce de Nathalie
et ce soir c'est à trois que ça sort un
peu comme un souper presque parfait je
trouvais l'idée le fun et moi j'aime
cuisiner je me disais après Nathalie ça
pourrait être moi
rencontrer des gens avec qui cassaient
la croûte ça demande un effort tout
comme demandé des portions adaptées à
nos besoins aux personnels en épicerie
avez-vous déjà commandé quatre tranches
de jambon au comptoir de charcuterie
c'est gênant en fait la seule solution
que j'ai trouvée c'est d'aller dans des
commerces spécialisés sauf qu'on
s'entend aller à la boucherie oui tu
peux avoir exactement la quantité que tu
veux mais le prix est à l'avenant aussi
[Musique]
c'est une personne seule c'est toi qui
va devoir faire les démarches pour faire
adapter le système pour toi et la
question de la charge mentale aussi
quand on vit à plusieurs dans un foyer
on est plusieurs personnes qui peuvent
prendre la charge de planifier les repas
de d'aller faire les achats de préparer
de manger de te faire la vaisselle
toutes ces tâches-là sont associées à
manger mais là ça retombe toutes sur les
épaules de la même personne quand on vit
seul donc c'est une super grosse charge
mentale
les sols de la semaine sont aussi
souvent appliqués sur les grandes
quantités comme les formats familiaux ce
n'est pas toujours possible de les faire
appliquer sur des articles à l'unité
conçoit dans la viande qu'on soit dans
le pain qu'on soit dans le poisson peu
importe même les fruits et légumes dès
que c'est prêt emballés avec une marque
oubliez ça on peut pas faire changer le
format qui est là les seuls produits
pour lesquels on peut avoir un peu plus
de marge de manœuvre c'est ce qui a été
emballé par les piscines si la promotion
est au poids donc un nouveau prix un
prix réduit au 100g à ce moment-là qu'il
y en a une ou qu'il y en a 12 dans le
paquet vous avez accès au même rabais
donc on a vraiment avantage à surveiller
les rabais qui sont au poids entre
autres pour les produits frais qu'on va
dire pour éviter le gaspage alimentaire
prendre portionne finalement ton gros
format puis congèle là j'ai déjà eu deux
frigos un congélateur c'était toujours
plein de mon petit congélateur de frigo
c'est pas long quand on des fois je fais
de la nourriture pendant une heure une
heure et demie pour 10 15 minutes avec
mon livre ou avec le Téléjournal
et j'ai envie de retrouver ça les
discussions la connaissance découvrir
des gens une des recommandations qu'on
donne puis notamment Santé Canada le
donne dans le Guide alimentaire aux gens
seuls c'est donc manger en bonne
compagnie parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
sciences en arrière qui montre que les
gens qui mangent ensemble sont
généralement meilleurs santé physique et
meilleure santé mentale que les gens qui
vivent seuls on sait bon appétit ouais
là il y a la variété Nathalie prend tout
ce que tu veux un petit peu de tout avec
une belle compagnie un échange juste ça
ça vaut de l'or
[Musique]